welcome back to New rockstars the second
trailer for Spider-Man across the
spiderverse drop and it looks amazing
the animation and every spidey's design
is absolutely perfect this director Duo
could not do any wrong but there's a ton
of small Easter eggs and major reveals
that you might have missed and there's
no better Duo to help break these down
for you than myself and Jessica Clemens
hi I'm very excited to break this down I
am so into it but first remember to
check out nerdriot.shop where you will
always find the latest and greatest in
new Rockstar's merch it's a great way to
support the channel and look incredible
while you do it check out all the
awesome merch options over there at
nerdrive.shop empty are you wearing one
I'm wearing some Amanda merch I love me
samando merch 24 7. um you're always
wearing the merch I'm so proud I love it
I love being some star I win a huge Star
Wars pick so I gotta be where my man
don't work perfect this trailer is I
don't even have to say it but it's
beautiful and maybe hopefully by the end
of this breakdown we can figure out why
miles wasn't invited to join the Spidey
for us why he doesn't get a special ban
and who actually dies because it's a
Spider-Man movie and I don't care
someone has to die because it's
Spider-Man it just can't be spot because
I love spot it can't be spot he's uh
he's doing he's too stupid I love him
he's just like I don't know what I'm
doing but it's like he's so dumb
yeah I can't wait to talk to you about
the ATM scene so let's start right
okay so we opened the trailer the same
way we closed the Spider-Man into the
spider-verse with Miles introducing
himself in a little monologue as
Brooklyn's one and only Spider-Man as he
swings around what I can only assume is
Brooklyn I think more specifically it's
his school because of the tunnel we
passed some traffic and there's a bus
that reads the spoiler which could be a
place map for a small spoiler in the
movie but also is the villain of
Spider-Man from back in the day
introduced by the electric company if
you don't know what the electric company
is you're too young but also if you do
know what the electric company is you're
too old and it's also just like a
villain called the spoiler all he does
is spoil things whether it's your meal
or it's like a movie that's what he does
and it's very perfect sounds like my ex
anyway continue
thank you we're back we're back to a
rush Miles Morales at his school
sprinting down the hallway and we got
some decent looks from this scene in the
last trailer the Puerto Rican flag this
is a newer suit that we saw in the last
movie so the buildings in area are the
Fabrica de sodas which is just a soda
store they make sodas there we got the
Puerto Rican imports and exports a
bakery this is a very busy area and
let's try not to forget that in the very
first trailer we got we know that
there's some sort of block party that's
going to be happening which gives way
for some other information a little
further into the trailer now this
license plate appeared and into the
spider-verse as well and in the last
breakdown I did I was trying to figure
out what it could mean I started
searching the internet and I think this
Twitter account actually solved it so
the license plate says tt1207 and this
is the date that the premiere of into
the spider-verse happened in Malaysia
the movie was also pushed to release
December 14th so there's a potential
that animators just expected this movie
to come out December 7th and it didn't
only in Malaysia congrats to that
Twitter person because I that's wow
that's really great I just want to note
this classic art the Band-Aid dots when
he jumps midair this is only the
beginning of the intense artwork the
animators illustrators put into this we
have so many looks coming down the
pipeline at least six major ones and a
little big fun fact also they're
graffitied on the wall you see right
there it says the word Smo s-m-o-e I
think that's how you say it okay now
this is a German graffiti artist monoba
who actually made a lot of the graffiti
art for the Insomniac Spider-Man games
and it looks like they just brought it
over from the Insomniac Games into
across the spider-verse that's perfect
because he's amazing it feels very
graffiti heavy so like it's perfect for
the Miles Morales movie Spider-Man is
clearly very stressed you can tell by
the unenthused gray really gives it away
you know in the overlapping a lot of
sass yeah I'm gonna get into it right
when he opens what I think is the door
store rooftop we see what got him really
rushing he's carrying a big pink box the
classic kind you use for pastries this
is definitely the block party that's
happening the balloons flowers it's just
perfect also there's a little Greenhouse
I just want to live on a rooftop here
it's it's gorgeous and his parents are
pissed because he's late Rio played by
Luna Velez and Jefferson played by Brian
Tyree Henry now clearly our boys under
stress in the first trailer we got more
in-depth reasoning for Miles parents
concerns Rio said she worries as miles
is growing up and no longer needing her
it doesn't help when the guidance
counselor later tells them he's lying to
you and I think you know it our boy is
growing up and being Spider-Man adds
some extra Years to you so though this
movie really fluctuates around Gwen and
Miles chemistry the other Spider-Man and
all their worlds I think it's important
to stay grounded remembering how miles
is still a young man and hasn't been a
Spider-Man that long and with a family
that loves him dearly and like a worried
parent should they're concerned with
what they don't know also I think I said
whatever to my mom once and she hit me
with the TV remote we're moving on
we're finally introduced to the spot and
oh my god dude the 102nd Dalmatian he is
the goofiest thing that they could have
given us he's a little knock knee too
all good me too baby it's all fine it's
all fine but spot your built so
ridiculous so there's a lot of things to
take away from his first villainy
appearance number one he doesn't know
how to use his powers he's creating a
portal clearly to steal money from the
ATM and his hand is coming out on the
other end this leads me to believe when
he inevitably sends miles or Gwen or
whomever through one of his portals he
doesn't know where they're going sort of
like America Chavez now spot was
originally a research Scientist by the
name of Jonathan on that stepped into a
janky ass machine that was meant to
duplicate the cloak's powers and then he
gained a portal spot covered body so
he's a physical walking portal of space
warps and he literally looks like a
Dalmatian he is the 103rd Dalmatian I
freaking love weird Marvel characters
and Marvel villains and like he is like
top tier weird and like I've been
waiting for the spot to appear it's some
Spider-Man movie or project and like
this is perfect this is absolutely
perfect I'm eating it up okay and
secondly he knows currency and disguises
so even though we made him look like a
dork he knows he should be hiding in
this little Bodega the spot is also
played by Jason Schwartzman truly the
biggest dork of them all I love him also
good to keep in mind the spot will be
the villain spanning the two-part movie
so it'll probably accomplish what's
needed in the first movie to segue into
the second one and great he's clumsy too
and the most disgusting way we get a
gander at his powers in action he
literally touched the bread and it fell
out of his stomach it's the slightest
touch that makes his powers work which
is a recipe for disaster this is
literally the worst thing you can do
accidentally touch things and they go
somewhere else and when miles attacks
spot begins to back into his portal
furthering my theories that spot was
originally supposed to be a Spider-Man
and something butterfly affected him
into being the villain spot instead at
the end of into the spider-verse those
edges around miles from Gwen popping
into his Universe the pink bubbly ones
resemble the one spot has here his are
just gross and murky and those damn
Birds always get in the way we jump to
the guidance counselor Miss Weber who is
definitely Rachel Dratch I I don't even
need to look it up I know for sure
that's Rachel Dratch the name Miss Weber
could be a shout out to Steven Weber the
voice actor for the Green Goblin and
Venom in The Ultimate Spider-Man I would
also say it could be a shout out to
Charlotte Weber one of the newer
Spider-Man but that's two B's instead of
this one B additionally I was like she
could be an older Rogue because of her
white streak but that's me going very
Rogue with a very Rogue Theory hey I
support get it you get it it's a joke
and it's a good one she's talking to Rio
and Davis about miles's school report
which okay let me tell you much better
than mine he got an A in AP Physics I
didn't even make it pretty damn good I
didn't make it to physics I stayed in
algebra the entire four years so anyways
right when miles storms out of the
guidance counselor's office the song
play in his black way and black caviar's
what's up danger featured in the first
film and on the first film soundtrack he
also has some graffiti work and BLM
patch on his bag and you just gotta love
him and when his mom snaps when his mom
snaps the little Puerto Rican flag
colors pop up it's I love that touch
I love it then right there his Spidey
senses began to tingle and it's the spot
just straight up stealing an ATM
straight up stealing an ATM he literally
has the shape and mind of Bigfoot it's
he what was he doing if he's on top of a
roof he's
his way into probably destroying the
spider verse and I love that I really
hope it that's why he's the villain
that's why the villain because he's so
disastrous with nuts I love him so much
okay thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video movies and TV can
be great escapisms but when it's time to
face things head on better help is there
to help better help is the world's
largest therapy service and it's 100
online with better help you can tap into
a network of over 25 000 license and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues to get
started just answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's just
right for you after that talk to your
therapist however you feel comfortable
whether it's via text chat phone call or
video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge
betterhelp gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more schedule flexibility at a more
affordable price get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com new rockstars
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash new rockstars for 10 off
your first month of therapy we jumped to
the scene we got in the first trailer
Miles trying to relax and listening to
music when Gwen arrives the anti-social
Social Club posters ASAP Rocky's long
live ASAP album poster a parody of
course this poster says the way of the
butterfly with what I think is Muhammad
Ali we have top skater on Playstation
with Spider-Man on it you know this is
just like a young a young man's room and
we know this scene from the original
first little across the spider versus
teaser where miles is confirmed grounded
and Gwen goes oh is Spider-Man grounded
and it's this cute little like Romeo and
Julia juxtaposition and it's a great
shot then We're Off to the Races miles
is blasting through the hexagon portals
things we've seen in the past trailers
but this dialogue is very new and very
important he says so wait a minute
there's an elite crew with all the best
spider people in it like Lord and Miller
confirmed in the Spider-Man after party
they said in regards to Gwen you get
invited into Oscar Isaac's cool spider
Force he goes on to say you get invited
and miles does it and you sort of can't
tell him why also I don't want to toot
my own horn but I've also been invited
into the Spidey Force it's a super
secret and very real I know I got it's
super secret and very real and these
texts aren't faked I swear to God empty
these texts okay now it's suspicious
they're not fake I didn't use the AI
apps to make the fake I didn't do it hey
hey do I know if I'll be spam later
absolutely not but I'm part of the super
secret Spidey team so I don't even care
here's the text to prove it we also get
cutaways to a very pregnant Spider Woman
which could be pulling from the 2015
Spider-Woman where she is indeed
pregnant but also a private investigator
we get a sick so freaking cool Glimpse
at Hobie Hobart officially he wasn't
present in the last trailer and the
comics he was the leader of the spider
Army he led his supporters to Rally
against his universe as president
Osborne they smashed his head with a
guitar
yes I love it very cool smash his head
in with a guitar I mean that's metal as
hell you guys they mentioned in the
after party using Daniel Kalua being
from Camden the birthplace of punk and
you see it really in his design it's
giving very 70s British punk rock the
design is messy rebellious and it feels
like a do-it-yourself scene behind
spider Punk is spider Gwen and Bobby
tripoder I can't make it where they are
but it looks like the lab all those
computers are there this could be Alco
Max and they're running from something
though whatever this pink bubble is that
seems to have them trapped is actually
opening we jumped them with pavitra now
we got a great glimpse of moonboten in
the first look trailer last year but we
haven't seen footage of him in the
universe so seeing him now and his
element is perfect his suit is literally
impeccable I'm a fan it's much different
than the one in the comic but this one
feels like it reflects more traditional
Indian clothing he's also voiced by
Quran Sony and he's already doing a
great job and I'm very proud of him then
we jump to what I call the citadelos
fighties but Gwen calls it the lobby we
saw it in the last trailer which has a
ton of Spider-Man so please refer to my
last breakdown pointing them out for the
scenes we didn't see in the last trailer
we'll be going over the those fighties
regardless even if we've seen them
before it's a new shot so we have to
break it down so don't fret we have them
ready for you don't come at me this is
when it gets fishy because Gwen says
Miguel O'Hara this whole thing was his
idea which could mean Miguel created the
lobby or created the Spidey Team Force
or both I think it's actually both we
see him later in the trailer give Gwen
her Spidey ban the team band the one
what we've seen throughout the trailer
but also featured in the post-credits
scene and into the spider-verse and that
one was a prototype so he's been working
fast everyone has the same band or some
sort of band everyone but Miles when
Miguel tosses Gwen her band her art
looks different more melancholic and I
think what we're seeing is Fire Woman
and Miguel portal denzelis to Gwen's
Universe to give her that van when
Miguel is introduced he uses a sort of
energy whip to pull him through the
portal it retracts back into his band we
then get Miguel beating the crap out of
vulture which absolutely has to be at
the same time Spider Woman Jumps through
on her own motorcycle drifting on his
chest the color schemes on the back are
similar we're getting a glimpse of a tag
team Spidey beat down and I'm obsessed
with it then we're taken to a new shot
of the lobby in this shot we have in the
back Kobe AK spider Punk and look at his
hair we have miles Gwen and Spider Woman
in the front we have the fortnite
Spider-Man Earth 982 Mayday Parker I
think this is MayDay this Mayday just
has like a triangle on her suit so a
slightly different variation of the kind
I think this is Earth 91240 Spider-Man
from Secret Wars battle World clearly
miles wants to join but Miguel is
against it even referencing doctor
strange and Peter on Earth 19999 which
is clearly a reference to no way home so
is it not 616 or
199999 and Far From Home Mysterio also
referred to Earth as earth616 Christine
even referred to it as 616 as well in
the Multiverse of Madness so it's safe
to say in the MCU we're just calling it
616 because we're also there and that's
how we see it as 616. most Sony
properties there will see it as Earth
19999999 and that's just on the Marvel
and the Sony the structure of the
building the company not reflecting the
comic book material just in money and
that's when we're introduced to our baby
boy Peter B Parker take it away Mt ho
yes oh my goodness I freaking love Nick
Miller so I'm very excited to see Peter
P Barker once again speaking of babies
after Peter B Parker crawls into frame
wearing what I'm assuming is his
supermodel wife's fashionable robe it
could be his robe I know just pink looks
nice and a pair of cool dad slippers we
finally get the arrival of his daughter
Mae Mayday Parker to the big screen
named after Peter's Aunt May May Parker
was introduced in what if number 105 as
the daughter of both Peter Parker and
Mary Jane Watson who takes up the spider
mantle as Spider Girl and then later
Spider Woman after Peter loses his leg
in a battle with the Green Goblin but
here in this movie it seems that Mayday
is still a baby a baby who apparently
may be able to web swing without visible
web shooters because we don't really see
web shooters on our hands and I mean
unless her little pink bracelet is a
hidden web shooter in Disguise or maybe
she can just naturally shoot webs out of
her body like Toby Maguire Spider-Man
but she looks so much like MJ though
with her red hair and blue eyes on top
but is dressed like her spider dad with
the Red White and Blue on her bottom and
I love how she lives up to the nickname
mayday as she carelessly crawls along
the walls with a missing sock so
something tells me that she's gonna be a
handful in this movie and the trailer
seems to be edited to look like Miguel
doesn't seem too happy with Peter
bringing Mayday along which could be
alluding to his loss of his own little
girl from the first trailer but as he
rubs his eyes we can see from his
computer screens that he seems to have a
whole digital map of the spider-verse
itself that he projects around the room
in both of these trailers it's
definitely making me feel like Miguel
might be trying to Monitor and control
the fates of everyone in the
spider-verse like he who remains did
with the TVA I feel like the spider
Force could actually be kind of bad and
unethical which is why um the spider
Gwen says we're supposed to be the good
guys in the first trailer I think it's a
pretty good reason for miles to want to
rebel against the entire spider Army so
that he can decide his own fate right
when miles meets up with Peter we can
see a long-haired spider Punk hanging
out with Miles and Gwen looking like the
cool ass punk rocker that he is like
miles better watch out because let's
face it Gwen and spider Punk have a lot
more in common you better set the game
up my boy better sip that game up as
mile swings along we can see a variant
of the New Yorker build in the
background before Spider-Man 2099 tells
Peter that being Spider-Man is all about
sacrifice as we see spider brand holding
the dead body of a dead Peter Parker
Spider-Man possibly implying that Gwen
might have gone to seek out miles
companionship after losing one of her
spider teammates on a mission like she
probably couldn't handle seeing another
dead Peter Parker after losing her Peter
Parker in her original universe but
anyways I feel like this line is
incredibly important because it may hold
the motivations behind Miguel and the
spider Army much like the TBA was
promoting timelines for the good
Multiverse and Loki Miguel might be
ensuring that every Spider-Man goes
through a massive loss so that they can
learn how to become a true Spider-Man
which is why important losses like Uncle
Ben are necessary to every spider
timeline a notion that Miles seems to
reject outright when he's forced to
choose between losing someone he loves
potentially his father who seems to be
falling in this trailer and the health
of the spider-verse someone echoing the
hard choice that Peter Parker had to
make between Aunt May and the sixth city
of New York at the very end of the
Spider-Man PlayStation game as miles
takes a dive in Spider-Man India's world
of mumbatin we can see a no number of
interesting advertisements around him
like one for the bank of mumbatin a
production of sitarist on the roof which
is a parody a Fiddler on the Roof and a
lightning energy drink by a doctor Shaka
which could be the universe's version of
the Spider-Man villain shocker after
that we get the introduction of another
strong spider black woman spider bite a
spider woman who fights crime in
cyberspace who made her debut in the
pages of voltos Fighters number one
Spider-Man 2099 then charges after miles
with super red eyes which were actually
a side effect of his spider mutation
that allows him to see in the dark and
detect heat signatures like the freaking
Predator then we get a peek of the
spotted Dimension the dimension that
this weird-ass criminal the spot travels
through when he wants to teleport from
place to place with powers like that in
this movie I wonder how he'll unlock the
ability to travel to different universes
because he is linked to cloak's Dark
Horse powers in the comics as miles
continues to swing around lumbatin to
catch a spider Gwen in free fall we can
see a billboard for sacred Wars which is
a hilarious take on Marvel's Secret Wars
comic and cinematic events which is how
hilarious and before miles runs away
from Spider-Man 29 it seems like he may
have let out a massive blast of Venom
power that knocked all the spider people
to the ground a blast that Peter B
Parker Shields his daughter from like a
good daddy and after we get this wide
shot of what appears to be Spider-Man
2099 futuristic city of Nueva York that
Miguel and miles are chasing each other
around we get a shot of spiderwin in her
room with a sign that says protects
trans kids which I thought was a nice
touch considering that you know
protecting trans kids is something that
irresponsible hero would do and B the
colors of the trans flag match well with
the pink blue and white of Gwen's
universe and super suit this makes sense
her entire universe protects trans kids
that's a great Universe hey right that's
a good Universe why can't our universe
get on the same page and as Gwen and
Peter are crawling on this train we can
see that Peter seems to have given his
daughter Mayday his mask to wear to keep
her feeling brave as he puts her in
unbelievable danger like they're on top
of a train what are you doing you're
gonna lose the kids I'm telling MJ I'm
telling MJ so I can steal MJ from you
because let's face it she's too high hey
hey out I'm very curious as to why he
brought this little baby along because
it does seem that they were sort of
viewing from their situation because
he's dressed up like he's about to you
know have breakfast our babysitter's
really that expensive or our spider
people invaded they don't have it in
their Universe they just don't have like
affordable babysitters but speaking of
this train it quickly seems by a sign
that says Metro lunar implying to me
that this scene takes place in the city
of New lunar York of Earth 449 on Earth
where Humanity has colonized the moon
and where spider moon man lives and this
train appears to run directly above the
traffic of the city with massive
hologram warning signs for drivers to
please mine their speed in Spanish on
this train we see a massive crowd of
spider people chasing after miles and a
lot of them seem to be random original
Creations for this movie but there are
some VIPs of note among this crowd like
lady spider a white Spider Woman a Manga
versus Spider-Man a Mark II bulletproof
Spider-Man Captain spider Flash Thompson
and a massive cyborg Spider-Man and
after this mile says everyone keeps
telling me how my story is supposed to
go nah imma do my own thing as his body
blows blue seemingly in preparation to
Venom blast Spider-Man 29 off of his
body as he seeks to defy the fate of the
great Web of Life and Destiny has for
his life possibly trying to save one of
his parents from dying and in one of the
most hyped moments of the trailer for a
lot of Spider-Man fans we finally get
our boy Ben Riley the Scarlet Spider
front and center looking clean as hell
you're looking so cool he looked good he
looked good my goodness I can't believe
you finally got him and at the end of
the trailer while all the spider people
are doing the pointing meme that
seriously needs to die now we don't need
to do this joke anymore okay we're in
the same boat we're in the same boat I
got it I get it
I get it yes you've done you've sold it
for the capitalism it's time to go uh we
can see Spider-Man Unlimited and
Playstation Spider-Man starting the
point off with yet another Spider-Man
Unlimited variant popping up in the very
next frame that Spider-Man truly is
unlimited but we can also see superior
Spider-Man and Captain spider slash
Thompson among the pointers as well
along with like a spider Knight and we
cannot forget my main horse Widow the
spider horse crashing the spider therapy
session at the very end completely
destroying the spider Rorschach test and
red and blue Spider-Man themed bookcase
but we also cannot forget to mention the
international trailer because it
features the Spider-Man logos and voices
of Toby Tom and Andrew Spider-Man very
much implying that Sony is indeed
leaning hard into the renewed
relationship with Marvel and with the
sequel tool process by reverse being
called beyond the spider verse I would
very much expect to see miles Gwen and
the crew Venture on over to the MCU
sometime very soon but that is it for
our breakdown in Easter egg video for
Spider-Man across the spiderverse thank
you Jessica for joining me on this
amazing breakdown of like I can't wait
for this movie so much like freaky I
need to see the Scarlet Spider Ben
Reilly do some cool tricks in front of
my face immediately but let us know how
you guys feel about the trailer in the
comment section below and make sure to
follow Jess at Lulu underscore Clements
follow me at masterton and follow new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more breakdowns of everything that you
love thank you guys so much for watching
we love you guys so much goodbye bye my
Spidey sentence
[Music]
foreign